and the rays are going to go with a
little bit of a throwback here tonight
and that's going to be the opener and
that will be john curtis he's done it
one other time that was back on
august the 20th soto is out on strikes
fastball up gets him one two three go
the nationals
we head to the bottom for the nationals
gonna be right-hander annie ball sanchez
making his ninth start of the season
last time out was against the rays
went five innings gave up three earned
runs and picking up his second win did
all of that
on 88 pitches that's a lighter in the
left gonna drop for a base hit
the hop in front of soto and rosso is
aboard
but nate lope now longwood off the bat
of nate lowe that baby has
distance and is gone
home run for nate lowe ray's take a
one-nothing lead
that's a hot shot base hit back into
center field
backhanded stop roblates will hold
keermeyer
to a base hit he had two bases in the
back of his mind
always does anything to the outfield
that's what kier meyer is thinking
you're going to have to keep me from
going to second base so a runner in
scoring position for the race on the
single and the balk
kevin smith there's a lighter into left
that's going to be in there and that
will score kermeyer
kevin crosses the plate and the range
lead two to nothing so
kevin smith comes through with an rbi
single
and a base hit the other way one man on
that left side
and low got it through so homer to right
the base hit to left
he's two for two tapper that's a
fair ball back at third the throw
bounces in
and out of the glove of cabrera and so
the rays will have two men
on well just fair it's not conducive to
staying healthy i think is the point
2-2 to ki boom and he's ripping it
tonight fair or
foul carter's two for two
so he's three for three against this
lefty
garcia will roll one through the right
side kibum heading for third and then he
stops and goes back whoa
look like he had it made one more get
out of this inning
two outs and a tough hitter and trey
turner he pushes off on two and two
lifted in the air to shallow right
nate lowe's going out he calls for it
he's got to play and yarbrough closes
the door on the nationals
he gets adam eaton and trey turner on
the ground ball and a pop-up
and the nationals lead second and third
there's a base head liner into center on
the first pitch and meadows
is the boards so they've intentionally
walked since sugo now
and the bases are loaded with one out
for margaux
and a liner soft liner one hop nobody to
take the throw at first iran will score
everybody
is safe and the rays make it three to
nothing margot has himself
a run batted in here
and graemer misses with that one to
force homer run
sobraso who was hit by a pitch scores
that run
is charged to sanchez
kevin kiermeier line drive at a base hit
into left
off the bat of kier meyer one run is in
here comes another man into score
two runs across the plate and the rays
lead
six nothing since sugo and margot score
on the base hit by
well with two outs the ray's been doing
this all season long
hit her like ian desmond and tell him to
be a juan soto
that ball is crunched into center
kiermeyer back it's going to one hop the
wall
right behind him and juan soto
pulls into second with the nat's first
extra base hit of the night
left side soto coming home on contact he
scores again
kurt suzuki brings him in 6-1 game all
right got one back
ryan yarbrough eight starts for
yarborough still looking for that
first win maybe he gets it here tonight
and you send a message hey guess what
both sides of the plate are mine
yarbrough really ate them up and when
you get a guy out there that has pitch
ability
understands how to use his stuff and can
command it
then you know you can have success yeah
bro five and two thirds of five hit one
run baseball
five strikeouts no walks he would be in
line to be the winner
back for eric thames now the pitch swung
on line drive up the middle to the right
of second
and it's on through a base hitter to
center field for suzuki
so he snaps a personal over eight with a
single to center and now jake knoll
will get his first chance with this
player substitution
and noel rips one up the middle man it
is
chuck and duck for sheriff here in the
ninth inning
the nats have two of the three men
aboard they need to get this thing
rolling one two pitch and a cut in the
mids he's out on strikes on the slider
to end this one and the rays are winners
they've taken the first game of this
two-game set it's a
6-1 final
yarbro's going to pick up the win he is
one and three
sanchez the losing pitcher two and five
and right now the rays moved to a
four-game lead on toronto
four and a half on new york pending the
outcome of that
toronto new york game